hello good morning yeah well my name is
Adam Smith and I am calling from
nobelprize.org which is the website of
the Nobel Prize in Stockholm Sweden okay
first of all many congratulations on the
award of the Nobel Prize okay may I ask
how it feels to be the oldest ever
awarded laureate so I I just about made
it huh you can't be deaden when you kiss
you are a winner of the National
Inventors Hall of Fame you can be dead
but I won that prize a couple of years
ago and I was very proud of that that is
the most I would say most important
prize I won may I ask are you still
experimenting in your home lab I am in
fact I'm writing a paper now that you
guys are disturbing in my into science
and hope that they'll accept it well I
guess that's the secret of successful
research career to concentrate on work
rather than distractions and presumably
you're amazed and delighted to see the
variety of applications that optical
tweezers have been put to well I
anticipated that it was pretty important
from the very from the touch from the
tego the thing that I love well one of
my heroes is is this guy the Stutsman
Anton
you know and he he's the guy who
discovered animals and he kept writing
to the Laurel society telling them and
sending them pictures and nobody paid
any attention to her until very much
later they want a sample of his
microscope and he said nope says if you
want one you have to do it yourself he's
a hero and it's good to have scientific
heroes
so you knew when you develop them that
you were that you were developing the
instrument that would allow you to probe
molecular processes yes
well look I was sorry I was interested
in in trapping molecules with light a
long time ago well my famous paper in
1970 that's the most impatient famous
paper I ever wrote and that I mentioned
our kills with life but I never thought
the living things like was supposed to
kill tissue they used what that was a
very much a surprise that was a big
surprise and one sec look I know I
should I got a lot of old stories about
what happened when I described catching
living things with white people said
don't you you certainly weren't
exaggerating how exciting well we look
forward to hearing some more of these
stories will you be coming to Stockholm
in December to receive sure are you
going to celebrate well look I'm writing
a paper now and I'm not that Phillip
celebrating about old stuff I got
something new
important I'm working on solar energy
and I think I've gotten some important
stuff and the world badly needs science
is climate change yep
thank you very much indeed that's an
important message I very much appreciate
your talking to me thank you and once
again
many congratulations okay you're welcome
thank you